hey guys what's up I'm joined with Jenna
today i'm justine we're sisters like
actual sisters not like sorority like
any of that stuff cuz sometimes i see
that in the comments actual sisters we
are going to make a cake for our mom as
you can see we have everything in front
of us that we'll need give nothing ready
yet but this isn't my plan okay give me
with your plate oh there's two little
colors in here so you're gonna make one
color I think one pink felt one yellow
velvet deliciously moist did I see a
mother thinking I don't remember I know
but that's it happy Mother's Day to all
your mom special make two cakes don't
have us to look like this but I want to
mix them together and make it a swirl
cake that'll look orange
no yellow and pink my orange oh this is
gonna be beautiful so it makes it makes
two things together oh okay we're making
them separate okay two egg whites yep
cool one una Oh Lois flash the splash
myself / flash channel was taking the
bow to the shell in there mommy will not
like he always makes us cake and it's
always good I hope bars is up to par
this is a teeny tiny Bowl nothing very
upset with me because I have not been
using a blender lately have a cheese
grater do i yeah that's wild that's okay
I'll use us first come first serve what
did you pour me any water
no we're hot 1/3 cup now soon as I add
water to pink oh that's wild
that looks like disgusting I need a
undisputed law 4 tablespoons of butter
just soften give me half years yeah yeah
yeah yeah it works out nicely
that's pretty soft pretty soft oh I'll
just put it in there what I think I need
to invest in a new you should get a hand
mixer oh I got butter all over my neck
yeah but you should get a hand mixer
it's great
really
here's the problem mine is not gonna be
mixed that well hmm
we're gonna make this nice little harp
harp and why isn't it mixing how's the
butter probably should have been softer
yeah but it's Sookie that's not okay I'm
still mixing I haven't given up yet
magic be here I'll give you I'm never
gonna let you down and we're gonna make
a chunky cake and hurt you I'm never
gonna say goodbye ready yep
I don't need a spatula you don't need a
spatula does it look like it you're
right that's why that's a watery cuz I
really really really mix it and then I'm
gonna just dump this in wow that's real
watery and I want it just to be like a
like just like shake see stuff okay I
don't think it's gonna work it's like a
latte why do I have a lot more than you
did I mess it up it's you polish water
you put in this cake is gonna be huge
how many 1 thirds did you oh it was wait
a minute
oh I filled it up all right ooh that
wait a minute mmm I want to talk about
it I think I did too I put one in 1/3
cup ah it's so good I because I was not
looking at this how we both dumb this is
oh my lovely lovely cake what's gonna
happen it's so watery I actually don't
know it's gonna been all over both
idiots
I didn't I did it real quick
and now I'm seeing the mist all right we
have a two cups of extra water in that
cake maybe it will disintegrate we're
going to find out we'll see you guys in
a minute
pinnate boo boo we'll see you in 35
minutes probably longer god it's gonna
be liquid liquid cake here's what I
would like to say this cake has like
almost three cups too much water in it
two cups too much water we messed up and
it's still very warm I had even have a
full mess up so terribly I think it
tastes okay no we're gonna find out but
this was our Mother's Day cake so I'm
sorry mom thankfully we live in
California and you wouldn't even get to
try this anyway because I think you'd be
very embarrassed with our work I'm
embarrassed
jeetu it smells good
I can't wait to cut into it because if
you guys recall we did like a marbling
to it
so be very careful cuz it's still a
little bit warm just pretty this color
is fantastic what are you waiting for
Mon this is for you do not judge our
love on the quality of this cake please
we'll get you something else yeah what
do you want ya guys leave us some
suggestions in the comments of what we
should get our mom because this cake is
embarrassing
yes it's pretty embarrassing is he icing
okay are you okay are you okay I'm
saying I musn't Sherpa a sweet Oh your
brand dishes are much better than mine
yeah that's okay we had anything like we
could put on top of the cake yeah should
we write mom on it now yes that was a
wrong answer this looks good our theme
ends sprinkles Oh cuz I'd like that's
not gonna work that looks as good color
is the icing yeah that was they didn't
think that one through she needs on a
white a white sprinkle with white and
pink sprinkles something how they write
so nicely and I don't know jack okay
first off that looks like nothing like
my name is done there's one end and like
a Z looks like bread res you're crazy
you're crazy I'll make her another
little Harpe up here and it probably
should have not done that let's make the
perfect Mother's Day cake that'll be the
title this is what I really want to see
what I'm gonna get a closer shot here
that's all molded together it's $1 it's
it looks like it looks like a cheesecake
that looks it's yeah show you guys what
what's happened where are we horribly
wrong this is nothing like what I had in
mind at all like look at this can you
can you guys see oh wow it's almost like
eating a sponge like look at this
maybe the edge is cooked oh oh no no no
that was terrible
no no all right no wallah room
happy Mother's Day if you're a mother
and if you're not in the US I believe
you've already had your Mother's Day I
think it was in February they're leavin
obviously this weekend so hopefully
you'll make yourself and your mom better
cakes that's crazy how science works cuz
we put way too much water in and nothing
it went horribly wrong and adding too
much blah the cake mask all right guys
thank you so much for watching leave
some comments below let me know what
you'd like me to cook or bake next god
I'm so upset
throwing in the towel thousand small
size